we got the story from cnr.com Governor
Ronda santis deploys National Guard to
Texas border quote if we don't have a
border then we are not a sovereign
country DeSantis who ended his 2024
campaign two weeks ago has promised to
deploy at least 1,000 troops to the US
Mexico border and addition to the
National Guard this will Mark the first
deployment of the Florida State guard so
that's that's distinct I suppose that's
where we're actually starting to see
some escalation Florida State guard my
understanding they're you can't uh
federalize them no they're separate
they're state so this is where things
are starting to get particularly
interesting the concern with Texas
National Guard being deployed is that
Joe Biden could invoke the Insurrection
act or just make some Declaration of we
can't enforce the law without your help
one of the criteria for federalizing a
National Guard is they can't enforce the
law through other means which could mean
he doesn't need to go and say oh Texas
are in state of rebellion he could just
be like we we love Texas but we're going
to need some help on that border so now
they're under my command but the Texas
state guard and the Florida state guard
not so much so with
Ronda sandis deploying Florida State
guard down there this will create a
contingent that cannot be federalized
and this will
solidify I guess State Supremacy on the
law or the states things starting to get
interesting this could end here or this
could contribute to a
larger you know look the federal
government is supposed to be of the
states the states go to the federal
government and the federal government is
formed basically like Captain Planet all
the states say you know with our
Senators combined we get boom federal
government sort of now it's basically
like yeah we do not see you as inch
charge and we are going to take it upon
ourselves to unite come together and
effectively form what the federal
government was supposed to be on their
own so they say uh according to the
article desis visited Tex uh Texas
Mexico border July of 2021 he sent both
state law enforcement officers and
members of the Florida National Guard to
assist he also sent 800 soldiers 200
Florida Department of Law Enforcement
Officers 101 state troopers and 20
Wildlife enforcers I'm sorry Wildlife
officers to assist Texas border patrol
in May of 2023 as well as five planes 17
drones two command vehicles and 10 boats
quote Biden has the authority to close
the border today if he wanted to he
lacks the will to get the job done he
lacks the capacity to see the problem
for what it is so the American people
are basically left scrambling it's kind
of sad I got to be honest that uh Ron
what if if he was just doing this while
running he didn't need to campaign at
all that was the wild thing about
listening to this speech today which is
it's just a totally different energy I
feel like his we we had campaign Ron and
now we have Governor Ronda santis and
and they're you know he's much more
confident he speaks much more directly
um all the criticism that he didn't have
personality you couldn't say that here
and again this is something that I think
he feels very confident he's been
sending support to Texas since
2021 uh you know different amounts at
different times he sent boats he sent
people he sent Wildlife agents I mean he
has really reached into every capacity
of the Florida government to say we're
behind controlling the Border um I I
think this is a good move for him in a
lot of ways I think you know personally
I think supporting Texas and what
they're doing is great but I also think
generally he is really putting himself
back out there as the governor people
remembered him as there's a meme you
know the meme where it's the guy poking
the stick at the things and he's like
come on do something it's Carl Marx
wearing a mask with a with a smiley face
and KL Marx is crying behind it and he's
poking Texas and Joe Biden he's like
come on do a War so there's an article
from New Republic mag's ugly new Civil
War Fantasy should be taken seriously
it's funny
because on the right for the most part
everyone's saying like no Civil War and
the left is saying boy they sure do want
a civil
war like you keep asking us I guess
we'll get it started no it's wild no the
left wants the Civil War to start
because then they can suspend the
Constitution no I think so too I think I
think the what what the you know
Republican L States is are already doing
is just saying well we don't consent to
being governed this way and so we will
resist I mean that was what I thought
was so powerful about the message that
Abbott put out saying our right to
self-defense is the supreme law of the
land and nothing supersedes that that's
the way this works and then every other
state that was like yes we completely
agree every other state that felt like
State sovereignty is ultimately
important step forward and it's
obviously not that surprising that it's
along uh partisan lines at least to me I
think Democratic states feel ultimately
that the the more uh concentrated the
closer their relationship to the Federal
government the more power they have but
that's that's not the case these states
are Banning together and saying we don't
want this and we're going to act
accordingly in a nonviolent way while
Tim was reading the list of everything
that disantis is sending to Texas I had
this terrible image of the federal
government stopping it in some similar
fashion as to like the Sherman neck ties
that happened in the Civil War where
they would like burn the railroad tracks
to stop the the movement of all these
like the food or ammo and stuff I hope
it doesn't come to that but at some
point I feel like they're going to try
to stop this from happening I just think
the federal points on federal highways
yeah or I mean I think the federal
government's next move is to say well
we're going to cut off money to the
states that are doing this that tends to
be their move to say we're going to you
know use the power of the purse to say
you this but I think that again the this
has become such a clear issue and it's
winning over moderate voters too closing
the border is being against closing the
border is actually not a popular
position here's what people need to
consider so Ronda Sanz is sending some
troops to the Border again I guess you
know it's Florida State guard this time
so can't be federalized geez imagine if
8 years ago someone came to you and said
in 8 years 10 states will have deployed
law enforcement and National Guard to
the Texas border in a standoff with the
federal government as the feds try to
break barriers to allow 10,000 criminal
immigrants criminal aliens every day to
rush through the country and the states
began to reject Federal Authority the
Supreme Court gets involved the issue
that I think we have to we have to
understand is frogs in a pot boiling
it's not literal
but when we're at the point
where Ronda santz a governor announces
he's sending a thousand troops to the
border which is in direct Defiance of
the federal government is trying to do
every day when something small happens
we get used to it at this point we've
already heard the news that 10 states
have deployed National Guard to the
Texas supporter now hearing that Ron's
adding more it's kind of like okay but
imagine how insane it would have been if
we went from 2016 to that moment nobody
would have believed this would ever
happened and I I can tell you cuz as
much as people like to say go Tim pool
talks about Civil War I kept saying this
will never happen this is not what
happens and here it is this is wild well
this is what I think is so interesting
about the showdown in Texas is it's kind
of this
manifestation of left versus right when
the left has the left seems to love the
federal government they they love
everything federalized they want it as
big as possible they want the almighty
federal government to be as big and
powerful and domineering as possible the
right is always very much about
obviously limited government but also
the sovereignty of the states and so
it's really the showdown between like
the states and the federal government
and it is like a left versus right thing
I mean to this point I mean that's it's
just like Co again with lockdowns yeah
you know there was people on the left
who wanted the entire everyone has got
it shut down ruin your life and then we
had the States you know decide
thankfully for some people it also
reminds me of um the wave of Governors
that banned uh Tik Tok on the you know
on state or on State Property State
Technology and it was a wave of
Republican government I think actually
the governor of Nebraska LED it off
first like two years early then Christy
gome bunch of this was the end of um of
2022 into 2023 but then at the tail end
there were like I think in total three
or four Democratic Governors that were
like yes this technology is risky we
have to step in and say you can't access
it because it's you know part of their
terms of service means they can access
everything's on the computer or browsing
data so if you're a civil employee
accessing someone's private information
it's actually a big risk um but it was
right at the tail end that there were a
couple Democratic Governors that were
like okay we're going to do this too and
I am wondering if you know in a couple
months that there's a a chance that you
know a more moderate Democratic governor
will say okay we're actually with Texas
on this one this is too risky to stay to
not be involved in W but it it's kind of
like the breakdown with law enforcement
too because you know the left was
screaming uh defund the police ban the
police like but they love the FBI they
they love the federal bureau whereas you
know conservatives are more like we want
law enforcement out at the federal
government like let's you know they're
marxists they love when they can we the
power against their enemies that's all
they do conservatives tend to be more
supportive or at least more sympathetic
to state or local police and they are
definitely more more distrusting of
anything on the federal level where
where are the where's the law
enforcement the
prosecutors from say West Virginia or
Texas why hasn't any prosecutor in Texas
filed criminal charges against Joe
Biden good question just outright and
let them argue he's
immune is he immune or not and let them
argue
sayl interview some CBP guys Customs and
Border Protection ask them why it is you
are facilitating human trafficking why
are you accepting handoffs from cartels
and when they say just what I was order
to do you can go okay who's your boss
and then finally you get to the guy at
the top you get to mayorcas or whatever
and then you can say Joe Biden was aware
of this and we want to criminally charge
him how about you start with a Criminal
uh uh criminal investigation into Joe
Biden and let them argue you can't do
that the president's immune oh is he
well I guess you got to drop those
charges against Donald Trump is it your
feeling though that the average liberal
or leftist citizen is behind Joe Biden
on this no yeah okay because my feeling
is that this is this is Biden kind of
acting on his own I don't feel like
there's like a ground swell of support
from the average citizen on the left not
that I've seen I've seen a lot of people
who basically put me in exile for things
I've said during Co come around to being
like agreeing with me on most things now
so but that's just me like I don't know
a lot of people I'm not in New York
anymore where it's a hard thing to
defend people exist oh yeah I mean but
New York has been really hard hit by the
all the immigration stuff right I mean
again credit to Abbott him busing uh
migrants everywhere the thing is with
the New York the migrants New York and I
can't remember the whole to Total but at
one point it was like 100,000 that had
arrived in New York but he had only
busted like 30,000 there which means
that there were migrants coming in
already anyways he maybe exacerbated the
problem by not allowing them to stay in
Texas but it called attention to an
issue that New York was already coming
under siege for and that's something
that New Yorkers day today you know I
might generalize them as being more
Progressive than you know someone
someone in another part of the country
uh they are having to face the realities
of immigration the way that border
communities had to and so it is an issue
that I think is sort of undeniable and
ultimately there are a lot of reasons
we've talked about you know the effect
of the fentanyl crisis we've talked
about the effect of human trafficking
human smuggling there are a lot of ways
to say this is a bad idea if no matter
where your sympathies fall and I I'll
clarify for the individuals in the chat
who lack the capability to hold more
than one thought at a time uh CBP
officers that are facilitating human
smuggling and work working with cartel
members should go to prison when you
interview them and you ask them why
they're committing these crimes against
humanity and they invariably just say I
was told to do it you now get criminal
implications on their superiors that
does not mean they don't go to jail but
right now politically the question is
does Donald Trump have immunity for the
actions he took as president and the
answer is yes unless he's impeached and
convicted if the Democrats think
otherwise then the political opportunity
is file criminal charges against Joe
Biden watch them come out screaming he's
immune and then watch Donald Trump's
question get to his his trial get
dismissed generally speaking
conservatives have not gotten wise yet
to the idea of weaponizing the courts
the way that the left has I got to be
honest I don't even look at it like
weaponizing but the left is weaponizing
and we're not even there's no counter
reaction is what I'm saying the the the
the anti-establishment faction is not
even attempting to enforce the law in
any capacity correct so when you've got
Joe Biden destroying property charge the
CBP agents with destruction of State
Property that's a felony nope NOP no
we're not going to do that you know hold
on someone gets an order to destroy
state property and the state's like well
I guess they're allowed to do it is that
a joke they don't they don't do anything
do you think it's be you just described
as anti-establishment do you think
that's part of it they don't think about
how to use the system to benefit because
they are generally anti- the system no
no anti-establishment doesn't mean you
oppose governance it's just there's a
reason why the establishment gained the
amount of power that it did and why
we're watching them I mean it's it's
it's it's wild man it's it's a bunch of
Communists that are willing to say or do
whatever they want for power and then
everyone else just keep saying leave me
alone okay well you keep doing that
they're going to they're going to keep
gaining ground wherever they can y I
feel like it I don't agree with it but I
feel like a lot of it has to do with
people being desensitized to the justice
system being so broken and having no
accountability on the left so when
people on the like look what happened
with like the the sex tape from the from
the senate or whatever fact they were
like we've closed the case we can't find
any evidence of wrongdoing the staffer
who fil at j6 getting you know all these
all this stuff put in prison all you
know being chased around like I we'll
save this one for the larger subject but
the guy who filmed the uh adult film in
Senate no charges none totally fun crazy
well they can't find evidence of
wrongdoing like that was the line that
there's literally a video of wronging
there's literally a video and they're
like we we don't know anything anything
could have
happened I don't get it but that I mean
I that makes people cynical and I think
that miscarriage of Justice or that just
sort of blind denial especially in this
case with compar comparing contrasting
it to J Sixers is interesting because
the more videos that came out proved
more and more that MH they were there
were so many people who were just waved
into the building I mean we had the
shaman who was escorted around th this
idea that there is actual video evidence
that some prosecutor has decided I'm
just actually going to turn a blind eye
to and in fact it seems like juries are
saying that doesn't count I think it's
beyond it's beyond that though because
we almost live in separate realities
there's people who look at those videos
and still see the thing they want to see
it's totally it's terrifying but I I
think you're right what you said about
the
desensitization of losing in the courts
it feels like we're always losing in the
courts and I mean to me even just based
off my own personal experience I feel
like there is a certain wokeness like I
I think that even the most do you have a
jury trial I didn't sorry I cut you off
no no no you're fine you're fine no I
took a plea deal as most people are
doing in these cases but I did have a a
trump appointed judge yeah which did me
no favors trust me and and in fact I
would actually argue that in most cases
the people who drew the Trump judges are
they're getting the worst because first
of all I believe that a lot of the Trump
appointed judges actually hate Trump you
know just because they were appointed by
Trump doesn't mean they were Trump
supporters or Trump fans it just means
they have a history of conservatism and
at some point they probably worked in
the Bush Administration or you know
something like that uh but in addition
to that I think that they feel like they
have something to prove you know like oh
just because I'm Trump appointed doesn't
mean that I'm going to go easy on these
Trump supporters I'm going to go extra
hard on them watch what I do and I think
that's happening with lot of
conservative judges around the country I
think it's another reason why we've lost
faith in the courts even if it's an
immigration situation whatever it is we
we just feel like we can't win thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net